you have been critical to Staten Island
then you get blowback what on Twitter
and stuff I mean yeah I don't have the
internet anymore but I mean I assume
that they're not very happy why'd you
get rid of the in other words you don't
have Instagram anymore I don't even I
don't have my password I have an account
in case I have to do something and I
don't know how to go on there and
doesn't every agent manager anyone in
show business I know you must develop
this social media profile you're a young
guy you have to I can't [ __ ] care I
don't makes me feel weird about myself
you mean putting yourself out there to
promote yourself or or reading the
comment kind of both it's just like well
what do you expect like whenever I think
us I'm like if I post something I like
and then people just [ __ ] all over a
you're asking for it you know it's like
that's why I love my radio career
because it was before the internet and I
was the Internet I could say [ __ ] about
anybody I wanted I could talk about
anything I wanted and nobody had the
ability to come back at me I controlled
was amazing it was amazing yeah now
every [ __ ] [ __ ] is on there and I
can't handle it yeah and if you want to
find bad stuff about yourself you can oh
yeah
very easily do you have a thin skin like
if somebody says to you you're a douche
you take it in and say you know what
these [ __ ] guys maybe they know
something I mean like I am able to let
it bounce off but like it bought it I
think it would bother anybody I don't I
want to beat everybody up but like you
can't well I would think also once you
start dating an incredibly hot famous
chick right then the [ __ ] really starts
because guys are jealous yeah I got a
death fret because I want it so in order
to shoot me in the face like a
legitimate because she's so hot well of
course you know saying that is I was
like am i bad ugly that if you want to
shoot me in the face they're like now
[ __ ] this guy like what did I do